2017 Monster Energy NASCAR Cup he is the
champion of the NASCAR world and we are
thrilled to have him here on the show
how are you Martin great man how does it
feel
I don't usually start interviews like
that but I think they are this is a
genuine question here how does it feel
Martin it's unbelievable I'm still uh
still not sure if I'm dreaming I waiting
for somebody to wake me up it's it's
just so many emotions and been through
so much so many years to get to this
point so feels amazing and hopefully it
keeps feeling that way for quite a while
well so what part of your journey has
left to mind while you've just soaked in
the fact that you've reached the
pinnacle here oh man you know honestly
just really the last 12 years in being
in the Cup Series in general just all
the ups and downs and the roller-coaster
career you know years that were really
bad probably stick out more than
anything and then just this just how
thankful I am to end up where I'm at
with the team I have the last three
years we've just continued to make
strides and get better as a team and as
a group and you know here we are so hell
of an accomplishment we're really proud
of it so what are you saying about what
would it be like four years ago and you
thought you didn't have a ride or what
what what are you talking about in terms
of the Downs if you don't mind us said
yeah I mean the Downs you know just when
I first came to Cup Series I had two
Xfinity championships right away oh four
oh five and went to cup and my rookie
year was was pretty decent my second
year we won our first race we you know
we made to make the chase a year which
now they call the playoffs and then that
team kind of fell apart no Dale jr. last
the team kind of kind of got dismantled
and I ended up going to different teams
so 2010 I went to Michael Waltrip Racing
same thing had a couple years to build
the first year or two was was tough and
we were we wanted to go when our first
race together we made the playoffs and
then the Richmond scandal happened and
and lost the sponsor and so I was
searching for ride again so just could
never put it put it all together you
know it takes it takes years it takes a
couple years to put together the team
and and and just the the the team and
and figuring
how to run all these racetracks in these
races in the notebook and all the things
it takes to be successful in our sport
takes a few years to build that as a
team and just every time we felt we were
getting closed it got ripped out from
under me so why do you think it all
clicked this year Martin we've been able
to keep it going we've got a great great
bunch of people got a great car owner
giving us all the things we need we've
had great partners and sponsors and just
been able to continue to build on on
what we started you know our first year
together we didn't win it all second
year we want a race you know two years
ago we won four races this year we want
eight races and championships so it's
been it's been an amazing amazing ride
but the ups and downs and you know my
girlfriend battling cancer
for the last couple years is a part of
it and just a crazy story how is Shari
doing she's feeling awesome feeling good
between treatments right now she has
another one coming up in about two weeks
but three more to go and hopefully
she'll be done forever how is her
battling and how she's handled it helped
you Martin with what you're doing
obviously we're we're focused on her and
her health but how is that lent
perspective to what you do and how you
go about doing what you do watching her
her her courage as closely as you do it
definitely changed a lot about the way I
think about everything you know I don't
think you can go through that as a
person or as a loved one of that person
going through it and not change your
perspective on life in general the way
you go about every single day you know
and for us you know when I talk racing
was that it for me my job was at its
lowest point she was going that said hey
things happen for a reason everything's
gonna be okay just continue to work hard
and do the things you know how to do and
it'll all work out and you know it turns
out that the worst day ever and in 2013
I'm sorry and uh yeah 2013 was actually
the best thing that ever happened to me
because I got put with this team and the
same thing with her she's just she's a
fighter she's got a great spirit I
learned that I'm lucky to have an
awesome job that's the greatest job in
the world
even on the worst days and I learned
that from her and I learned that it's
it's a blessing every day
to wake up and get to do the things you
love so she's inspired me a lot to be a
better person to be a better driver to
be you know just give give it all if
everything I have if I want something
and uh you know can control what you can
control
Martin Truex Jr 2017 NASCAR Cup Series
champion here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about the celebration portion
of this who have you heard from who sent
you text who dropped a voicemail that
you hadn't heard from a while or you
were surprised to hear from after you
won at all nobody that that I didn't
expect really friends and family and and
I my peers I think those are the ones
that probably are the most humbling you
know to see your peers and your
competitors happy for you is is probably
one of the one of the most gratifying
things that you could ever do so that
was that was neat my best my best pal
Dale jr. came came right to Victory Lane
there and celebrated with us for a few
minutes that was special and just just
all of it really just taking it all in
my friends and family I had so many of
them at the racetrack there that was
that was great so no no crazy celebrity
texts or phone calls or anything like
that out of the blue but it's been an
unbelievable experience and obviously
you can work on your your biceps and
triceps lifting the trophy right at the
base man 68 pounds yeah 68 pounds I mean
I mean where is it where's the trophy
right now it's actually on its way to
Denver I'm going to Denver on Monday to
celebrate with the team and and do some
things there with the city and we're
gonna have it on display so looking
forward to that
okay now you're from you're from Jersey
right you're a Jersey Jersey okay right
so does that mean do you have a football
team that you follow at all Martin I'm
an Eagles fan
there you go I totally figured you
because you're from Trenton South Jersey
that's that's like a that's like a
suburb of Philadelphia right Martin
well I'm actually from I'm from
manahawkin but yeah okay on the coast
jersey shore but yeah definitely a
Philadelphia sports team town mm-hm and
yeah always been an Eagles fan so pretty
jacked out about the season they're
havin yeah I bet
have you met when says if you ever
cross paths with wince or anybody else
from the Eagles at all you know I
I've I've been to some games before and
you know met Andy Reid and met some of
the players back a few years ago okay
haven't been in a while huge fan of went
you know he's an outdoors guy like I am
so one of these days maybe all get
together and do something yeah you a
trout I know Mike trout's a big fan of
theirs too from the baseball world cuz
he's a South Jersey guy
yeah I'm fan of his too so I've not met
him yet okay and like maybe maybe you
should bring the trophy to 2 Mile High
to Martin I don't know that's going at
or you could bring it I think that's I
think that's actually gonna happen is
that really you're gonna bring it to
know well they're sending it to Denver
right now so I'm not sure if it's going
where it's going but I'll be there
Monday so it should be fun that's
fantastic well Martin look I appreciate
you taking the time your story is
something that is inspirational to say
the least send our best we've never met
and I haven't met your girlfriend either
but send send my best to her what she's
been going through it's just amazing to
see her doing what she's doing and and
hearing this story that she's just a
couple of clean tests removed from
hopefully never having a test again so
hey if you are you come to Los Angeles
you know I would stop by our studio we'd
love to have you you got it well do we
done there I'd love it that's a Martin
Truex Jr
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience